Уже понад мільйон людей померли у світі від наслідків захворювання COVID-19.
У Європі посилюють заходи боротьби з коронавірусом і знову запроваджують суворіші обмеження.
ЄС на порозі нового локдауну?
Додаткові обмеження на кількість учасників різноманітних заходів, у тому числі урочистих подій,
обмеження на продаж алкоголю і навіть запровадження комендантської години,
якщо кількість нових випадків інфікування коронавірусом протягом тижня перевищить 50 на 100 тисяч жителів.
Про це домовились канцлерка ФРН Анґела Меркель та бургомістри 11 великих міст країни.
У Берліні з 10 жовтня вже діє так званий нічний локдаун.
Заборонено продавати алкоголь уночі та збиратися великими групами.
А ресторанам і барам наказано закриватися не пізніше 23-ої години.
Схожі заходи запровадили й в інших великих містах, зокрема у Кельні.
За словами Анґели Меркель, влітку все пройшло добре, але тепер німці знову спостерігають тривожну картину.
Все повернеться: вечірки, дозвілля, розваги без коронавірусних обмежень.
Але зараз важливе дещо інше: пильність та згуртованість.
Міністр економіки Німеччини Петер Альтмаєр на відміну від прем'єра Баварії і потенційного претендента на посаду канцлера
ФРН Маркуса Зедера не бачить необхідності у запровадженні другого локдауну по всій країні.
Розвиток ситуації у найближчі дні та тижні визначить те, які заходи будуть діяти взимку.
У сусідній Польщі запроваджено обов’язкове носіння масок в усіх громадських місцях.
При цьому, за словами польського прем’єра Матеуша Моравецького, влада має намір уникнути локдауну.
Маски можна не носити лише під час прогулянок у лісі, зелених зонах, парках, а також під час занять спортом.
Темпи поширення коронавірусу в країні за останні дні зросли.
Кілька днів поспіль фіксували рекордні показники - понад чотири тисячі нових випадків за добу.
У Чехії 9 жовтня було зафіксовано теж рекордну для країни кількість нових випадків - понад вісім з половиною тисяч.
Тоді Чехія стала третьою у світі за кількістю нових випадків за добу в перерахунку на 100 тисяч населення.
Через різке зростання захворюваності в країні заборонено будь-які культурно-розважальні заходи - попередньо на два тижні.
Закрито усі театри і кінозали. Не можна проводити масові спортивні заходи.
Тренуватися дозволено тільки на відкритих стадіонах, а всі криті спортивні об'єкти закриваються.
Крім того, від 14 жовтня в Чехії заборонено працювати закладам громадського харчування,
лише на винос, як під час локдауну навесні.
На дистанційне навчання мають перейти всі школи, починаючи з молодших класів.
Будуть відкритими лише дитсадки. До того ж, заборонено збиратися групами більше 6 осіб.
Стрімко поширюється коронавірус і у Франції. Там нині реєструють найбільший добовий приріст хворих.
Так, найбільший антирекорд 10 жовтня становив майже 27 тисяч нових випадків за добу.
Тож слідом за Парижем уряд запроваджує жорсткіші обмеження ще у низці міст
з високим рівнем поширення інфекції, зокрема у Ліоні та Ліллі.
Бари і ресторани в них будуть закриті, як і в столиці, де це сталося ще раніше.
Стан підвищеної готовності у Франції оголошують, коли рівень інфікування перевищує 250 випадків зараження
на 100 тисяч жителів і зайнято понад 30 відсотків від загальної кількості ліжок у реанімації.
Посилюють карантинні обмеження і в Італії, яка навесні була однією з найбільш постраждалих країн у Європі.
Люди щойно почали повертатися до більш-менш звичного життя після локдауну,
як знову з’явилася загроза його відновлення.
Уряд збирається заборонити приватні вечірки, а також обмежити
години відвідування для барів і ресторанів, заняття спортом та іншими фізичними активностями,
які не дають можливості носити маску.
З 7 жовтня по всій Італії вже запроваджено обов'язкове носіння масок не лише у транспорті та магазинах, а й скрізь на вулиці.
Ось так нині виглядають околиці Мадрида. На під’їздах до міста - патрулі поліції.
Столичний регіон, в якому мешкають понад чотири з половиною мільйони людей, фактично на карантині.
Попри судові рішення на користь противників обмежень уряд таки оголосив стан тривоги у Мадриді на 15 днів.
Це дозволяє знову запровадити карантинні заходи та обмежити подорожі до Мадрида
та виїзд з нього за винятком поїздок на роботу, до школи та з метою охорони здоров’я.
Для порівняння - у Німеччині зоною підвищеного ризику вважається місто,
якщо в ньому нові зараження перевищують 50 випадків на 100 тисяч населення протягом семи днів.
У Мадриді цей показник нині становить 700 випадків на 100 тисяч мешканців.